good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight just 36 days into a new
administration and already
joe biden has fulfilled a major campaign
promise
now if you didn't vote for him it might
be hard to admit this but don't worry
this is nothing that's going to improve
your life or the life of the united
states it's nothing that's going to make
you freer or happier
help you drop 20 pounds or bring you
closer to your family there's nothing
you can use to buy dinner
you're not getting a stimulus check this
week your kids are not going back to
school you're not getting a raise
you thought you might be back on the
campaign trail joe biden promised
low-wage workers a bump to 15 bucks an
hour remember that
sorry not happening not because hiking
the minimum wage might eliminate jobs
that is a real argument but it's not
relevant
to what just happened the minimum wage
isn't going to 15 bucks because the
senate parliamentarian
wouldn't allow it raising the minimum
wage to that level would violate
established procedure the
parliamentarians said of course the
white house wanted no point
no part of violating procedure as
biden's chief of staff ron claim put it
quote
we're going to honor the rules of the
senate and work within the system
okay keep that in mind when they try to
eliminate the filibuster or pack the
supreme court or make a dc estate
in the meantime though no living wage
for you that's one campaign promise that
joe biden appears to have forgotten
but the promise he remembered wasn't
made to you in the first place or to the
country it was made to defense
contractors and neocon think tanks in
washington
joe biden promised them that once he
took power the united states would
immediately
bring war back to the middle east after
a four-year respite
that really agitated people in dc and
when he did that biden said he wouldn't
consult congress or even the senate
parliamentarian before he did it
he wouldn't even pretend to quote work
within the system he'd just do it
and he wasn't kidding on thursday he did
it biden sent f-15s to kill people in
syria
now no one in this country benefited
from that not even in the smallest
most theoretical way and that in itself
was deeply reassuring
to the political class in washington
they consider any attempt to improve
this country a terrifying form of
nationalism ooh
it scares them but the idea of killing
people in a faraway place
thrilling i do think it was important
for the my administration to send
a message a very clear message early on
that these attacks on our forces will
not be tolerated we're going to take a
proportionate response that we're going
to respond
and we hit back at them and i think it's
just sort of resetting expectations
that if you hit us we're going to punch
back no one likes to talk about the fact
that we have to protect ourselves
but that's the national security reality
and i think the biden administration
understands it and they're acting
accordingly i think that
uh that president biden is pursuing a
tough but smart approach
is it a mistake to target bases in syria
right now
actually it was pretty smart this is
counter terrorism so i don't think the
biden administration needed new
permission
or authorization from the congress yeah
didn't need permission listen carefully
america killing strangers in syria was
not
pointless you don't know where syria is
but it was quote pretty smart to do that
that's the official word it comes from
experts who believe that stam had
bioweapons and started a war on the
basis of it
doesn't matter thursday's strike against
syria they just told us was
counter terrorism and counterterrorism
justifies all keep that in mind
going forward you don't want
counter-terrorism aimed at you let's
hope it never
is in syria counterterrorism means that
at least 22 people died according to
local reports
the pentagon says only one person died
but who were these people in any case
who was targeted
the bite administration says it targeted
two militia that are aligned with iran
members of those groups allegedly fired
a rocket into a rock that killed an
american contractor
let's go meta for a second you may be
wondering why are there still american
contractors
in iraq after almost two decades and no
obvious return and that's a good
question
maybe we'll address that some other time
because here's an even more amazing
thing
both of the militias the bite
administration hit are part of something
called the popular mobilization forces
that's a kind of umbrella group that is
sponsored by the iraqi government
now the iraqi government itself is a
creation of previous
american administrations so in other
words if you're following all this and
you have been for 18 years
we are now defending americans in iraq
from people we empowered
in the first place to fix a disaster
that was caused by our invasion that's
all
counter terrorism got it the snake eats
its own tail
now if all this seems demented to you
rest easy you should know it was
joe biden who did it it wasn't donald
trump it was
joe biden therefore it's fine in fact
it's good
here's an actual tweet from a former
wall street executive turned angry
social media person called amy siskind
quote so different having military
action under biden
no middle school level threats on
twitter trust biden and his team's
competence
trust biden it's a kindler gentler
missile strike
hilarious with joe biden in charge
buildings in syria don't collapse
into rubble crushing the people inside
no those buildings simply disappear like
distressed companies that people like
amy siskind melted down for profit on
wall street
naturally because events like this do
connect people in a certain way
david french used to work at national
review was also excited about this
war makes david french feel powerful and
alive one of the few things that does
but only when the right people wage it
so three years ago we're keeping track
of this david french was distressed by
the year that donald trump might attack
syria
without permission quote if trump
strikes syria without congressional
approval
his syrian policy will be both imprudent
and unconstitutional now that was april
of 2018
we were totally opposed to striking
syria at the time
but not because it was unconstitutional
it was just pointless
last week though david french looked at
dozens of people dying in syria inside
was satisfaction
good he wrote that he went back to
writing essays about what a fine
christian he is
maybe because she reads david french
jensachi came around too
she was once opposed to bombing here
without permission
here she was on thursday
the president is sending an un ambiguous
message that he's going to act to
protect
americans and uh when threats are posed
he has the right to take an action at
the time and in the manner of his
choosing oh yes it wasn't long ago she
was telling us it was
totally a violation of international law
to bomb siri without congressional
approval
now she's telling us joe biden is going
to act to protect americans
now you're not supposed to notice that
what was done to quote protect americans
who were still
stuck languishing in iraq 18 years after
the invasion
if we're going to protect them why are
we making them stay there what are they
doing there
and once again because it's the only
question that ever matters
how is this helping anyone in this
country or by the way in any country
well it's not obviously and to their
credit neocons have stopped pretending
that it is
what this is really about joe biden once
explained in public
is helping our kurdish partners here's
joe biden in 2019
fretting aloud that donald trump might
withdraw american troops from syria
by precipitously withdrawing
a small number of american special
forces in syria
trump managed in one fell swoop
to betray our kurdish partners who
helped defeat isis
to create a humanitarian crisis with
innocent civilians
and ethnic and religious minority
communities
caught in the crossfire
the best part was religious minority
communities
we're attacking the assad government
which is the only government in the
entire middle east that's protected
the most ancient of religious minorities
the christian community
they've been slaughtered except in
territory that assad controls but he's a
brutal dictator
that doesn't count but of course we're
doing all of this for our
kurdish partners did you know we had
kurdish partners
did you want them what exactly have we
partnered to do
no one answers those questions don't
sweat the details assure the democrats
the party that runs baltimore and east
st louis
has a handle on this they're going to
make the middle east a much better place
just like hillary clinton improved libya
now it has permanent war in slave
markets
and they're going to make you much safer
in the process it's called
counter-terrorism
it can't be bad